O
>> THEY AR HR R SEVERANCE BUT TR
E COMPAN
>>NATH THE ENEMYE UNTRY. SAID IN
TRUMP WHO MAHAAT
WITH THE MEDIA
A  TRUMP.TS HEREQUOTE, THE
COGTON
POST".
FIRST,'STHE
I JUST WANTO
THEY AREOT STRGHOUET
BREITBART,ST, CN
POST".WHAT DID YOU FD?
SO YOU GET THED SOOF US IN TIDEL
TAED OVERAGE THE FIRST FEW
HSWEVER,
BIDEN HAS BE AT E DONAOR LOWER A
S
IT
IT'S THE ACTUAL WORDS WE'R
USG.AT AIABI NOTE SO THAN WE WE
DONALD TRUMP AT A TI
S
THAT IS ANT OF TINDUSTRY>>AN ON
WORDWE" LUMPING THE "WNGST", Y
SAY, BREITBART OR THIS AGENCY D.
CAN YOU TELLTH
?ULD LOOK AT TBART SAY THEY DID
MUCHOSRAGE OF P,H
THAT BRINGS THE DIFF
>> ANDWO
WHAT'SCTUALLY INTERESTING IS UNO
OFT  WOULD BE TO B
BU D
HE'S TOO, NOOUS HEAS N
EQUIVEITBAR LEFTO THE
AER
M
NEWSPAPERS, MEDIIV
KNOW, IT'S NOTOFUT S NUMBER
WE NEVER H SUCH A NUMBER
W WE CAN STU
O
OKBOUT
"THE HUFFINGTON POST".
YOU ID HE.
S INTO EXCEL  GOING TO KE THIS.
"THE HUFFINGTON POST" IS PERHA
G A IC EYE FROM THEIR
POLITICAL AND T GOING TO
S TO REPUT NEWS VE SEEE WHERTHPA
DRAWDOWN.
INT.
BIDEN'S COVERAGE
FAVORABLE THAN TRUMP BEFOR
EYON
EVENS GERA SINCEN, IMPROVED.
SLIGHT UBUL EMPHATICALLY NEGATI
.
AGAIN, AT THE SAME LEVEL OR AT
TIMES EVEN MORE THAN WE WERE
AGT THINK THAT'S THE KEY.
YOU'R CONSUME
AND YOU CONSIDER YOURSELF WS
CONSUMF RETAZATIONS, WHAT DO Y
E ?
>> I LOOOM THEOI
OF NEWPRODUC DO SO SEARC
SEE WHAT WE ARDE
CONSUMER SHOULD LOOK
ATHAH A
ADVERSARIA
ADVERSARIAL.
BUT THERA ROBLEMWE ARE BEING AD
ANOTR IS TRYIN OVERTHROW
DEACY.Y WEIV RBEOKG  THIS LAST D
THE LAST YEAR OF THE TRUMP
H
EAR. IF YOU'RE LOOKING AT THOSE
A SIGN THATS AR
K AT THEM OVERALL,
.U CAN PICK O OR
THAT IS TH ADONE BETTER THAN TH
BUT K IT'S ANYTHING UL
- THE MEDIA AS ALE -- , TH
SHOULD BE VERY MUCPSIDED THEWAY
TTINATP AS MUCH
HE THE
BREITBART IS PUT OUT FP
>> WE SHOU OUR JOB
.
THAT'S WT M TRYING TO DO.
>> I LKE YOUR ANALYSIS AND CONS.
>>T IS A DEFINITION.
>> IF YOU CONSIDER
THATHING
GETSPHERE, RIGH
BECAUSE T OFE  BREITBART AS NEV.
>> THIS RIGHT.
AI CAN DO THIS IA WAY THATN .
UE
NOT EVEN RECOGZE ABOUT
ADJECERE THEY ARE PS. O B O
GO, HOW MUCH DO YOU TRUST THIS T